Kim is with us in Detroit Michigan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Kim
better than I deserve what's up in your
world well we were kind of well we were
really dumb and we went and got em not
just one payday loan not just two we
have four out oh my goodness you're
desperate weren't you yes we we were
very desperate but now we're even in
bigger desperation motives we are
watching the payoff we've got one that
we've paid we owed 1,400 and we've
already paid 1,500 on it and we've only
made $100 into the balance okay and so
what is what are the three the reed
loans today what's the balance today one
is 1,300 we've got two out that we just
keep flipping around it and they're each
at 600 they cost us 675 every time like
it's 75 every time you flip it every pay
day and then there's another one out
there for 1,500
thanks man and what's your household
income I make about 25 thousand a year I
picked up a second job working about 60
hours a week on top of that when we
realized we were in trouble so I'm
working anywhere from 80 to 100 hours a
week right now and that's paying me $9
well almost $10 an hour now and then $15
an hour an overtime and then my husband
makes $40,000 a year and he's looking at
getting another Dave job we started
watching he wasn't totally on board he's
like no he's like a budget isn't gonna
help us and I'm like I'm telling you it
will if we just like try and figure this
out we have to work our way out of this
there's got to be a legend of the debt
do you have we have our mortgage our
house payment is $1,300 a month it's at
an extremely high interest rate we're
still trying to
and we've got two cars that are almost
paid off how much do we owe
2001 and we owe 3000 on the other but so
basically you're telling me you make 25
plus your job and he makes 40 what's the
deal more 50 it's overtime that's 65,000
between the two of you Tremaine jobs and
on top of that so you guys are probably
approaching probably approaching a
hundred thousand dollars a year with all
the overtime both of you to pick it up
oh yeah I mean we're trying to get back
on track our problem is is that stop
stop stop
just listen okay hundred thousand
dollars and you hear me that five
thousand dollars pays off both your cars
another five thousand dollars pays off
these student loans so less than ten
thousand dollars pays off and your
debt-free but your house and you're
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
right so you are disorganized oh we are
you desperately need a budget we started
on every dollar yeah you did he didn't
write he didn't get on board until I
showed him your so credit start credit
Sark's ensued and then he's like that
kind of makes sense to me like the like
we don't need here's what here's what
Misha makes sense to you a hundred
thousand versus ten thousand that says
to me you should not have this pain
right that it's that simple those two
numbers right there on a piece of paper
written down it's kind of stupid that
it's so simple and so you guys have got
to got to get organized the two of you
have to sit down and put all of your
income in one pile and buy the food by
the lights and water
hey the house payment clear these $600
payday lenders clear the 15300 then
clear the fifteen hundred then clear the
$2,000 car then clear the $3,000 car you
should be
get free by fall okay I mean think about
it we and we have the problem that we
rent that we've seen is like his Chuck
came in and we still lose like his take
home was on this last pay day day
fourteen hundred we lost to those payday
loans because they come directly out of
our checking account we have since had
them shut down we went to the bank and
said do not let them take any more out
of our checks and by the time he did
everything we lost close to six hundred
and fifty of that just no that's none of
that's the point the point is you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year and you
only need two n okay ten cleans up not
just the payday loans it cleans up
everything if I wrote you a check for
$10,000 your life would change
completely for about ten minutes if you
don't get organized and get yourself on
a detailed plan where every dollar of
income has an assignment before the
month begins every dollar has an
assignment before the month begins you
guys can do this this is very doable for
you and if you don't clean it up I mean
if you call me up and you're making
twenty five thousand when you said that
I thought maybe that was your only
income for a minute but by the time we
end up working through your whole income
now you got control you stop those guys
from take cleaning out your check that's
a good thing you stopped this from
happening in that from happening that's
a good thing but let's get this budget
going and stop your 401 KS I don't know
what's being withheld over at work being
taken out of your checks at work stop
all of that you guys desperately need to
get this organized and get focused
because twenty-five hundred dollars a
month out of eight thousand dollars a
month should be going towards these
debts and in four months you would be
debt-free completely give or take the
payday loan so we'll say five months but
by Christmas
easy-easy you are dead free completely
and that's what you've got to do kiddo
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content
and check out these other great clips
from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]